welcome to the present from
ecuador rafael correa
good afternoon
now i have the opportunity to introduce
today's speaker my name is oscar i
am a professor of
physics and microbiology at this
university of yale the history is
present for program planning and development
formerly give back to
the entourage of the present correa and
like some of the work that
is being done in my laboratory every
year from 2008 to 2014
take undergraduate students from yale and
ecuador to the
ecuadorian amazon
amazon where we collected
samples of plants that we studied in  the
university and jito and here at yale the
present visit correa is very
meaningful to me it may be the
equator amazon rainforest
is where many have fallen in love with
field research and many have
been inspired to pursue
a career in  science these
students have discovered
potentially beneficial organisms that  e reside
in the plants of the tropical forest they
have now identified organisms that eat the
plastic that produce a fuel of
simple sugars that fight
diseases and much more without a doubt
there are many more
scientific discoveries to be made through the
of this discovery of microbial diversity
the  wild cables that are a treasure
for the country and for the world I hope that there
will continue to be opportunities for the
people of Ecuador to discover these
sites together as I have traveled
to the equator for a short period the
first two weeks of March every
year of 2008  2014 has given me a
very unusual perspective on this
country, I don't see it every day but I
see it with a brief annual perspective
where I can compare the progress of the country
from one year to the next and we start our
visits shortly before everything shortly after
that I introduced Correa became
president
I have seen his vision for
economic development unfold  of
negative resources committed to infrastructure
and education and this is evident
throughout the country right now three
weeks ago when I was there there was a
bridge in coca two years ago there was a
new airport in quito this year and
there was a new airport in esmeraldas
on  The country has been transformed during
his presidency and I have had the
opportunity, year after year,
to witness these advances of
special interest to us, made from the
commitment of this current year to
make a significant investment in
education and technology, now
four new ones.  public universities
under construction in ecuador including
the construction of the first
planned city on the continent that has a
technology-focused university
in the center there is also a university
being built in the
rainforest with hundreds of
square kilometers of rainforest set aside
for  Being able to study is a
visionary investment in the  future of ecuador and
south america mr. correa studied
in ecuador in belgium in the usa has a
doctorate in economics of truth
in 2001 he returned to his country and was the
finance minister before being a
candidate for the presence in 2006 not
only  he won that first election but he
has also been re-elected twice
by wide margins interestingly on
the last trip the election had just happened
and then there were photos of
president correa all over the country
photographed with various
local candidates their governments have managed
to reduce the high level  of poverty
indigence of exemplary an ecuador continues to
enjoy great popularity of ecuador
and highlights the educational opportunity for
ecuadorian citizens today the
present of correa will talk about his vision
for ecuador and for south america in
a talk called
the political transformation of science  in
the knowledge of Ecuador
generously the present of mail
offered to answer some of  the
questions that have been presented by the
members of the public present and I am going
to offer these questions to the present
so we are going to welcome you
back to the present ecuador rafael
correa
thank you very much
as professor robert mentioned we are going to
try to talk today about
the political transformation of
science and technology of Ecuador
for me it is a true honor to be able to
share some ideas with the
academic community of this very
historic and prestigious university.
luck
and receive a master's degree in economics and a
doctorate also in economics at the
university of illinois in
urbana-champaign during four of the
happiest years of my life
and well, studying is very good
and when I returned to Ecuador I got to
work as a teacher  university and
I dedicated my life to teaching and
researching in the area of ​​economics and
development  I do believe me when I say that
there is only one thing that I like more than
teaching and that is learning and that is why I
feel envious of you of
course I am glad to be able to serve my
country
to the best of my ability at
a time when
that politics offers many
disappointments i sometimes want to go back to the
classroom i want to express my deep
gratitude to yale university the
workers and the professors and the
students for this invitation
let me tell you about a fascinating country the
most compact megadiverse country in the world if
we consider the  terrestrial and marine diversity
ecuador has the largest number of
species
on the planet in a territory
of just over 109
square miles approximately the
size of the state of nevada where one
finds all imaginable climates and microclimates
in ecuador we have four worlds in a
single day a  tourists can have breakfast on
the Pacific beaches with
freshly caught sea fruits and then have lunch at
the  foothills of cayambe
wonderful andean mountain that has snow all
year long just above the equator and then have dinner
deep in the mosunic jungle the
next day after a flight of less
than two hours our astonished tourist
can find himself in the galapagos islands
one of the seven  natural wonders
of the world ecuador loves life in our
constitution it is the first constitution
in the world that grants rights to
nature 20 percent of our
territory is protected in 49 reserves and
national parks including
yasuní park a treasure of the jungle and  a
world biosphere reserve where
in one square kilometer one can
find a greater variety of trees
than all of north america without a doubt
in view of its diversity and its
geographical location ecuador is the eco
center of the world in ecuador in seven
days it can take  a sample of all of
latin america' its beaches its mountains
its jungles its islands and most
importantly its  People,
as I said yesterday in the presentation in
Hartford, Argentineans proudly proclaim
that their father is Argentinean, my dear
friend Dilma Rousseff, President of
Brazil, the eternal rival between Argentina,
soccer, and other things.
brazilian
in ecuador we have no problem
with that by the way the father is argentinian
and it is probable that god is brazilian
but paradise is ecuadorian you
are always welcome in ecuador
dear students and teachers
dear friends and friends after
years of studying development i can
ensure that development, at least in
the Latin American context, is
fundamentally a political problem, a
problem that rules in a society,
the elites or the great majorities, the
capital or the human beings, the society
or the market, the
institutions, the programs and
policies of a country  It depends on who
has the power. This was already known years
before by a French thinker.  és frédéric
bastiat and he quoted when looting
becomes a way of life for a
group of men who live
together in society they create for
themselves
a legal system that authorizes
and authorizes them and a moral code that
glorifies it  For the purpose of quoting, the greatest damage
that has been done to the economy is to
separate it from its original nature
as political economy. They have led us to
believe that everything is a technical issue
and by not considering
power relations in a society, they
have subjugated us to the
ruling powers paraphrasing the great
economist john kenneth galbraith an
economist who recognizes for us the
issues of power is completely
useless
political economy during the period
of the citizen revolution that's what
our political project is called the citizen revolution
political economy during the period
of citizen repression  has
enabled
and carried out a constant reduction in
poverty
and inequality of December 2  007 to
2013 poverty has fallen to 11
extreme poverty from 69 to 86 and the
gini coefficient has decreased by 8
points the growth of the
Ecuadorian economy has been in favor of the
poor
the rate of income growth
among the poorest has  been faster
than the increase in income for the
richest this situation suggests a process
of socioeconomic convergence in
Ecuadorian society there is a
constant reduction in economic polarization
during the period analyzed the relationship
between the income of the 10% richest
and the 10  % poorest
fell from 35 to 1 to 24 to 1, that is, a gap
that still cannot be justified in
morality, one observes a process of
territorial convergence, which means
that the reduction in poverty is greater
in those provinces that had the
higher levels of
poverty before our government
professor es troben mentioned the
very beautiful new bridge in coca it is a bridge to the
amazon the region had nothing and and  t is the
most modern bridge in the country at this
time we have included
historically marginalized sectors. A clear example
is that as a result of the policy of
eliminating economic barriers and
having recovered quality public services,
educational enrollment has
increased steadily with the
largest  gains in the poorest quintiles
the public policy
that we have implemented has made it possible
to strengthen the middle class
and
although we can observe an improvement in
the standard of living of the entire population in
terms of income, one out of four out of
four Ecuadorians has gone to a
higher economic stratum, that is to say, there is
clear evidence of
upward social mobility
to give you an idea
of ​​where the country is headed and the
social trends continue by 2015,
we will have achieved all the goals
stipulated in the United
Nations Millennium Development Goals.
clarify that for us
these
goals represent the minimum levels
acceptable since our own
programmatic agenda as defined in
the national plan for good living is much
more ambitious, reflecting what our
country really needs
according to
the
2012 unit nations human development report during the
period from 2007 to 2012, which coincides  with
our government ecuador is one of the
three countries in the world that has advanced
the most in terms of human development has
improved its rating from a
medium level of human development to a
high level of human development
as a result of the crisis of 1999
million ecuadorians  have emigrated
were forced to leave the country, which
destroyed families and damaged the
social fabric. In addition, the economy was
reduced by 7.6 percent, unemployment
shot up to almost 15%, the national currency was
eliminated and the dollar was adopted as
the  country's currency was really a
social tragedy but these emigrants
are our heroes they are the ones who
sustained our country with  the
dollars
and they work so hard to earn and that they have
sent us to overcome the crisis several
of these migrant Ecuadorian citizens
came precisely because nobody evans
thanks for receiving them
and they have to appreciate their sacrifice
because they really are modern heroes the
instability was such
the instability was such  that until
2007 no government was able to complete
its term in 10 years
seven presidents today
ecuador is one of the most
stable democracies in latin america since 2006
the citizen reduction has won 10
consecutive elections including 2
iu presidential elections in the
first round lo  which was unthinkable in
the recent history of ecuador
we have the highest levels of
popular approval on the continent
democracy has been firmly established
in ecuador not only formal democracy
but real democracy in terms of
people's access to rights to
equal opportunities  and
decent living conditions
and  This is the so-called Ecuadorian miracle,
even though there are no miracles in development,
the impressive changes that have
taken place are basically the result of the change in
power relations that has been
achieved through
deeply democratic processes. Today in
Ecuador, the Ecuadorian people are
in charge,
but  the problem of development is that it
requires
and many necessary elements, none of
which in itself is sufficient,
power can be in the hands of the
great majorities,
it is possible that a
more equitable distribution can be achieved, however,
it is possible that only misery will have to
distribute the  science and technology
as drivers of wealth are
fundamental to development
this is probably
the secret to the success of the usa a country
where 1% of the population controls
35.6 percent of the wealth and 10% of the
the population controls 75 percent
of the wealth
this concentrated power normally
destroys a society
but
It is a system that has made
great technological advances possible and with them
improvements in productivity and income
that have improved life for all,
although we have made certain
important leaps in Ecuador in
social and political terms, this change has not been
accompanied by changes and improvements.
important in the productive sphere and
one of the most serious problems in
Ecuador continues to be the drop in the low
level of productivity in its economy
to resolve this gap between
social policy and production we have
adopted an aggressive national policy
to promote the development of
science  technology and innovation
in which universities play a
fundamental role
could perhaps indicate that the usa
has not fallen more than it has fallen in this
global economic crisis thanks to the
role played by these
excellent universities, for example yale, in the
economy of the  country, we are not
falling into the trap of absolutism,
this crisis is  in which all of
society has to be organized
according to technological requirements, it
is said that albert einstein said i fear
the day when technology
surpasses our human interaction the
world will have a generation of idiots
but we also do not believe
such a clever infantile fundamentalism in
the  that pre-
modernity is considered equal to good living and
misery is part of folklore and not only
that, these fundamentalisms
almost reach the point of irresponsibility, they
lend themselves to the new and unfair
international division of labor, as we will see in
a few moments, you should know that today  Nowadays,
new knowledge doubles every five years.
This means that those countries that
do not generate knowledge are
twice as ignorant every five years and,
above all, twice as dependent on
what others produce. Either
we seek to reduce the distance or
we will end up  isolated and subordinated
as a developing country
in terms of innovation and
science
p  For these reasons, higher education
has been a fundamental focus of
our government's policies for
which it has received recognition in
Latin America. Many of our
neighbors
have been surprised by the
strong wave of reforms that we have carried
out in recent years.  Now it is
known that Ecuador is known
as the country that established the gratitude
of public higher education and has
done so in its constitution,
the country that closed four universities
due to their terrible quality and the country that
increased over seven years.  Its investment
in higher education from 11
percent to 2 percent of GDP,
thus demonstrating a strong
political will to make knowledge, the
training of human talent, and
science and technology the pillars of the
new equator.
The results have been amazing from any
perspective.  with
significant improvements in the quality of
universals and democracy
democratization of access thanks to  Coming to
cost eradication and a meritocratic
revenue system, to understand these
remarkable changes we have to go back to the
2008 Constituent Assembly that
had the responsibility of drafting a
new constitution when it came to the
debate on the state of our
higher education system the
Assembly members had to
admit that Ecuador's university system did
not compare favorably
with many of its Latin American neighbors.
This finding was even more worrisome
in light of another finding that
Latin American universities,
notwithstanding
a few exceptions, do not compare
favorably with universities.  In
other parts of the world,
obviously including the US,
without a doubt,
the wave of regulation during
the strongest period of
neoliberal policies in the 1990s and early
2000s was
especially negative for our
higher education system. Universities
began to appear  r on each street in
Ecuador between 1992 and 2006, that is,
14 years, 45 universities were created out of
a total of 71 universities throughout the
country, many of which here in the US
could be called a degree factory or
ghost universities, we
call them  universal garage in
latin america are
for-profit businesses run by
unscrupulous people who virtually
sell the title to
naive students or in some cases not so
naive as a direct consequence of
this growing anarchy in
higher education the constituent assembly
ordered an evaluation  profunda
of the 71 universities in 2009
a first report was issued by the
accrediting entity of ecuador
placed the universities in five
categories from a to a- and the country learned
with astonishment that 26 of its institutions
were in the category that
is more than the third  Part of the
universities of Ecuador were
exposed in this evaluation as
institutions of very high  poor quality
had to have a new law on
higher education that was adopted in
our national assembly in 2010 to
present an ultimatum to these 26
universities show better
significant improvements or they will face
closure at the end of a new
evaluation process to be carried out  carried out within
18 months of the adoption of the new law
the second evaluation was carried out and
in April 2012 14 institutions that
did not deserve to be called universities
were closed
to ensure the rights of
students who had enrolled in
those institutions on  The
Ecuadorian government developed a complex contingency plan
that was undoubtedly the
largest academic intervention in the
history of Ecuador. The sole purpose
was to correct
one of the biggest social lies and scams
that the country had
experienced. More than 40,000 students
had been  enrolled in these bad
universities
and were bailed out by the state and
were  enrolled in the other
universities in the country, not only were
14 universities closed, but
we also closed 44 out of a total of 86
university extension programs, that
is, they were satellite campuses that
operated at a distance from the
university headquarters, these were created at a
time  in which mainly for
political and electoral reasons
the mainly
public universities opened extensions throughout the
country supposedly to decentralize
higher education the result was
a disaster
the poor rural areas
gave them third-
rank universities as political favors and the
result
was evidently that  the
vicious writing circle of discrimination was
exacerbated you can be loyal to the poor
the worst feelings and services
in addition to the relocation of more than
40,000 students we have also
elaborated more structural responses
to the phenomenon of poor quality higher education
at a decentralized level there was the  you  Having
universities with a certain scale and with a
national reach is an important part
of the solution, especially if it is
accompanied by donations and scholarships,
stipends from student residences,
etc. so that previously
excluded sectors can access
higher education.
Another important solution must be  To do
with technical and technological education
is something that in general in the Americas we
have not valued as much as we should
value it. In this sense,
Europeans
have proven that not all the
student population needs to study in
universities but that there is an
important part up to 60  In the case of
Germany, they can study in
more technical and
professional establishments. In the case of Ecuador,
a country with very ambitious aspirations
in terms of the diversification of its
economy
and the transformation of its
productive matrix, including a strong drive
towards industrialization and improvements.  in
productivity it is fundamental  ntal having
a highly qualified
and technically trained labor force is why
we are investing more than 300 million
dollars to strengthen and in many
cases build dozens of
technical institutes from scratch that are
strategically located and
strategically articulated to the productive sector does not allow
us to  Let's forget that the universities
that
closed specialized
mainly in cheap programs to
optimize profits, especially
in the areas of business administration
and commerce, or business administration
and commerce, are important areas of
study but it has a decline in maintaining the
employment market and a  even
lower impact on transformation, power,
production, and productivity,
technical interlopers help make
education relevant to
national development preparations in
one instance, many of the problems
that have been addressed in
Ecuador's higher education, including  the fraud
ac  ademic that correspond to
well-known recurring phenomena in many
countries of
latin america and the world, but
unlike other countries that face
challenges similar to ecuador, it had the
political will to address
this issue and bear the
economic cost of the contingency plan
as well as facing the possible political cost
of the conflict
that the closure could
generate the closure of the universities
sends a strong signal to the university
to the university system as throughout the
message was very clear Ecuador
needs a quality higher education
to the  service of
social and economic cultural change
as a result of this national cause, that
is, to improve our universities,
some quality indicators have already
improved between 2009 and 2013, the
number of professors with doctorates
has almost doubled, there are many more
full-time professors  professors
full-time teachers especially
in a context  In certain
private universities that did not have any and
therefore did not have any
academic or scientific community, we
have doubled the number of
publications in indexed journals and
Ecuador also has the highest
growth rate in the
innovation index in the region, this would be  a
world economic forum for 2013 and there have
been significant improvements in
infrastructure, better among
and other elements the argument that there
were no funds for these improvements
cannot be sustained because there are many
universities and have made
significant investments in
expensive university extensions
another strong incentive to  improving
quality was the design and
implementation of a new formula for
the distribution of state funds
for public units
before our government the
universities receive their budget
incrementally it was never more than what was
received the previous year and they received a
certain quality for
independent student  Apart from the cost of the
program this was of course an
incentive to offer cheap programs
of little relevance today the formula for
the allocation of state funds to
state universities considers the
true cost of the programs as well
as their quality this has been shown to be very
effective for  universities can
optimize their efforts towards quality
new national rules for
tenure also mean that
professors receive a decent or
dignified salary in public universities in
fact they are the most competitive academic salaries
in the region this along with
other policies that stimulate the
return of the ecuadorians who
left the country for the juve de cerebros'
has been successful in promoting the
growth of a profession and an
academic career in ecuador
nobody and at the same time everyone was a
university professor everyone taught
classes next to the part of  their other
professional activities but few
were full-time academics  or full
new salary and disability
means an increase of almost
90% in the salaries of academics
over 5 years, in addition to the
prometheus project, which is a system of
state scholarships that allows the recruitment and
hiring of
international academics fully paid by
the government of ecuador to work in
our universities has helped
increase academic excellence the
lasting solution for our our
higher education is to improve its
human talent and
as we enter the emergence of a new
generation of academics fully
dedicated to academia is one of the
reasons  For which Ecuador
currently has a reach of 8,000 scholarship recipients,
most of them
are postgraduate students at the
best universities in the world. I think there is
an example here at Jr.
Melissa Arias Melissa is here.
the highest investment in
scholarships per gdp in la america  tina and a
great commitment on the part of our
government in the last seven years we have
given more donations and scholarships than during the
entire history of Ecuador before
this government
if our universities
with some exceptions have been of poor
quality
does not mean that they have been of
easy access to the people, especially to the poor;
rather, they are the heirs of a system
that functioned as a mechanism for the
reproduction of the unequal structure
of social graces and
deepened the segmentation of
Ecuadorian society even further; the poor
could not enter  return in the sense that
as a government
we have refused to accept the
classic dilemma between equity and quality
where we are supposed to have to choose
between democratizing the system under the
principle of equity or favoring
merit and academic excellence in
accordance with the principle  of quality
our policies have shown the world
that it is indeed possible for both
principals  ipios combine
harmoniously and that this zero-sum game
is essentially a fallacy Ecuador has
doubled the enrollment figures for the
poorest sectors of society and for
the historically excluded
indigenous and Afro-Ecuadorian population, according to the
Economic Commission for America  latina
ecuador has become the country with
the highest percentage
of enrollment of the poorest quintile of its
population of all the countries in the
region
the constitutional guarantee of
free public higher education
has done much to democratize
access to  donations and
scholarships the new national system of
leveling
and admissions for higher education
has also eliminated long
waiting lines or queues and the use of
personal networks to enter the university
our system of enrollment on sight or
admission on sight of the  great
disparities that still exist in
secondary education is based on a
test that measures not only
Not only knowledge, but also skills and
abilities. Finally, we have created
four new
world-class public and therefore free universities
for the development of crucial areas of
the economy. The four projects seek to
combine quality, democracy, and the
relevance of respect for development.  The
first is the National University of
Education, now
dedicated mainly to the
training of teachers and specialists
who will be part of the national educational system,
it is evident that there can be no
sustainable generation
of human talent in the long term without an
excellent education at the level of the
early childhood and primary
and secondary education based on this
premise that the 2008 construction
establishes a
mandatory annual increase of 0 5% in the
education budget until it reaches
6% of GDP
currently the ministry of
education that does not have are  cities of
higher education handles the part
most important of the national budget
12 percent of the total we do not have
time to go into detail regarding
our policies in
general education but there have been great advances
in coverage, infrastructure and quality
unfortunately in ecuador as well as in
many parts of the world
teaching
has been  one of the least
prestigious and most desirable professions students
who aspire to be teachers on average
have the lowest scores on their
college entrance exams it is
time to change that reality to
encourage the most talented young people to
become teachers and give  prestige
to the profession to the noblest of
professions
the time here in creating that it is very
cold
and I was born in a very hot city one
of the policies that we have implemented
is a system of minimum standards for
different professions if a student
wishes to become  teacher has to
meet the highest standard as
well as the candidates  to
study medicine if a student is accepted
or a student will receive the
equivalent of a minimum salary during
the period of study that is, we
pay the students so that they
can later teach these
rigorous standards and importantly
important incentives accompanied by
the creation of the new university of
education seek to incorporate a new
generation of highly
motivated and qualified teachers into the system the
second university
three of the four have already been created
and there is another one that will enter in
September but universal of universal arts
teachers and  They have student classes and
all of them.
The second university that we are
creating is the University of the Arts
whose central mission is research,
creation, production, dissemination and
artistic training of the best talents in the
country in the arts and culture.
Culture and the arts play a role
fundamental in giving greater texture,
identity and memory to our  s
societies as well as deeper
deeper to our democracies
and we should not underestimate the role
that the cultural industries can play
in transforming our
production matrix as has been shown
in the usa where the cultural industries
represent 12 percent of
the gdp  The third university that we are
creating is called ICAM, which means
tropical forest in the
Suar language. It is the University of the Amazon
dedicated to the generation of
bio-knowledge. Professor Es Robert
has previously worked in our
Amazon region. Can you imagine a
world-class university right there in the middle of the
forest?  tropical that is and that the campus
is in the middle of a
natural reserve of 355 square miles and is a
living laboratory for the study of
biodiversity
and we believe it will be the great resource of the 21st century
if we want to affirm
sovereignty over the Amazon
we have  to study our fauna, flora,
aquatic and geological resources  gy the icam is
a response to this challenge and
finally the fourth university since it
means learn in the imperative
learn in our ancestral language
Quechua and that we have described as the
most important project in the history
of Ecuador is a university for
experimental scientific research
located  in an area beyond the north of
equator it is the cornerstone of a
new city of knowledge innovation
the first planned technology city
in latin america and kate that opened the
doors to the first students
last week is dedicated to
nanoscience the technology of
information vital sciences
renewable energy
and chemical sciences but
these new universities seek to put an
end to
ecuador's subservient role as a
producer of primary goods and
importer of goods with high
added value in the international system since
perhaps it best exemplifies the
aspiration of  a country
had given up resp  ect of the
generation of knowledge but now he
says we can and we dare to produce
science of course none of this is
possible without the political will not the
closure of 14 universals not granting
free education nor
the massive public investment that  what is
needed to create
extremely ambitious universities is not the other
thousand scholarships and certainly in the fact
that today ecuador is the country that
spends most of
its gdp on higher education with 2
percent of gdp ecuador  It is the
highest in Ecuador, where the average
spending on higher education is 0.8
percent of GDP.
In fact, it is higher than the average
spending in CD countries, which is
17 percent of GDP if we have
dedicated  so much energy so much time
political capital and resources to
higher education and science and
technology is because we are convinced
that the future will favor the
implementation that knowledge s  It will be
the cornerstone of their economies and their
social services. Today, public investment
is 15 percent of GDP, the highest
in Latin America. Those bridges and
airports and there are other
new airports that you have not seen, you have to keep
visiting us.  This translates into large
infrastructure works, new roads,
hydroelectric plants, ports,
airports, schools, hospitals with
activities, etc. However, an
earthquake can destroy the
infrastructure and leave a country in
ruins, but it cannot erase the
human talent of its people, and that is the same
human talent.  that science and
technology that allows countries to
overcome any earthquake as well as
any other challenge that humanity faces,
having presented a
panoramic vision of the importance that
we were attributing to
human talent, science, knowledge,
innovation in our government, I do not have, let
me return  to the main idea
I want to treat this  Lately, the results
we have obtained are not miracles, they are a
consequence of the fact that we have been able to change
the correlation of forces in these areas
in my country
by placing the common good of
the great majorities above all and not the
privileges of certain
corporatist groups; however, the
political dispute  It has a greater reach,
the one who has knowledge has the power,
pointed out the French philosopher michel
foucault,
the new cognitive cognis capitalism
created a
new dependency every day that microsoft
decides to release a new version of
microsoft off in the global south has no
choice but to buy its licenses  or
copy without authorization
the visible hand
of the market programs the obsolescence of
its products and you monitor it accurately there
can be no
possible emancipation if we do not break with this
new form of dependency we
seek to move from the economy of
finite resources to the economy of
infinite resources which we have called
the economy  social theory of knowledge and
innovation this economy also
seeks to recover
the concept of knowledge as a
public good knowledge in general
is a public good, that is to say, speaking in
technical terms, no one can be excluded
since we can all
access that  knowledge and without any
rivalry when it comes to consuming it
since my use of knowledge does not limit
anyone else from using it as I said
answer
if you have an apple and I have
an apple we exchange these
apples then you and I
will still have one  apple each but
if you have an idea and I have
an idea
and we exchange these ideas then
we will each have two ideas
and trying to privatize a public good
through institutional means for
example patents harms
society as a whole because  if there is no
rivalry in consumption, then
as the number of people
who enjoy this good increases and  it has created greater
social welfare this is one of
the famous market failures there are
some economics students here yes
well I lack of solidarity but it is
important to take this into account
it is one of the famous market failures
it is a dramatic example of the
privatization of the  of knowledge and
exclusion bland force is the high
cost of certain certain medicines since they
have patents
the apparently pragmatic principle of
the privatization of knowledge in addition
to its social inefficiency normally
subjugate human beings to capital
the great challenge of humanity
in the 21st century  is to achieve the supremacy of
human beings over capital
we need societies that dominate
markets and not societies dominated by
markets the market is a great
servant it
is a terrible master we believe in
societies with markets but not
societies dominated by the market in
which  the lives of people and
society itself are treated just as  or
other merchandise, all based on that
pipe dream called the market,
there are more efficient ways to promote the
production of knowledge. An
alternative is greater participation
by the academy and the
public sector itself. Another alternative is for the
state to
compensate the creation of knowledge.
for profit and thus make it available to
all humanity The main problem
of all alternatives is that they tend
to
touch ideological fundamentalisms
and the empire of capital but let's remember
that the US, for example, had a
quasi-open system for managing
knowledge during its early
periods  of industrialization
only recognized national patents
and did not allow foreign companies to
register their patents,
although it is mainly the
rich countries that produce science and
technology in countries like Ecuador, they
also produce public goods,
we produce environmental public goods,
but in our case  For
all the pure air generated by the Amazon jungle,
the lungs of the planet without it when there have
been human beings, will suffer or would suffer a
fundamental deterioration. We, the
countries of pollution, and here we do not
receive any compensation at the same time,
the main polluting polluters
in the world do not pay anything.  by
the consumption of our environmental goods
but there is more I also do not want to recognize the
information that exists in our
biodiversity which is often singular
an example is the
and predicts a painkiller derived from
our multicolored frog the fart bates
tricolor a name in Latin for the
detail whose  utility only came to be
known thanks to the
collective and ancestral knowledge of our
peoples
that was extracted by
foreign scientists and exploited by
international pharmaceutical companies
without any benefit to our country
and sometimes it is thought that
generating environmental goods has no
cost, it is a mistake  reality is
that it can be  Very expensive not in terms
of direct costs but in terms of what
economists call the
opportunity cost today
and many demand without any
moral stance that the oil from the Amazon
stays in the ground but that implies an
immense cost in income not received
in  Every day that goes by with a child who does not
have school, a community without
drinking water or people who die of
diseases that can be prevented,
all these true pathologies of
misery, is this the new
international division of labor if before it was
us producing the raw material and
the hegemonic countries producing
industrial goods with high
added value now the new unfair
international division of labor is these and
they generate the knowledge that
privatizes that they privatize and we
produce environmental goods that continue
to be free global public goods it
is also a
political problem a problem  of
power relations at the international level because par  To
illustrate this, imagine for a moment if
the situation were the opposite and the
generators of public and
environmental goods were the rich and
powerful countries and we, the
polluters, would certainly
have already invaded us to force us
to pay fair compensation and all
in the name  of civilization
civilization rights etc.
dear young students friends
friends
the world order is not only unfair it is
immoral
everything is aimed at serving the
interests of the most powerful and
double standards abound
global public goods produced by
poor countries have to be free
For example, environmental goods,
while public goods
produced by hegemonic countries
have to be paid for by imposing
institutional barriers such as
patents, only by compensating
for environmental goods
will there be an unprecedented redistribution
of income at the international level, but
again it is a  pro  problem of
power relations this time on an
international scale
the big polluters refuse to
sign kyoto but in our countries you
go to jail if you don't pay to use
a patented product
and the saddest thing is that often
poor countries themselves participate  enthusiastically
such absurd mechanisms and we do not even
understand the instruments that are
used to maintain ourselves in the role
that has been assigned to us by this
new division of labor, for example,
as our dear friend Álvaro
García Linera, Vice President of Bolivia,
one of the greatest
Latin American thinkers of this time, there is someone
from Bolivia of the present. Well,
I congratulate the Bolivians, they have
an outstanding vice president, as Álvaro
has said and I quote several NGOs, they
are not really non-
governmental organizations but organizations of
other governments in our territory and
the vehicle to introduce a type of  of
colonial environmentalism that relegates the
peoples  indigenous people the role of those who are
going to take care of the amazonian forest end of
appointment
by investing in human talent
science and technology by promoting
innovation we will overcome the economy
that is based on the extraction of
natural resources but in an
intelligent and responsible way  and sovereign without
the absurd situation of sitting on
a sack of gold
and begging instead of using our
natural resources to satisfy the
needs of our people, we know
perfectly well our limitations
as a small country and that we
cannot change an unjust world order,
but  We are not going to passively accept
the role that has been assigned to us
in
the new international division of labor
either.
immoral to
which we are subjected
dear students teachers friends
friends I firmly believe in the
transformative power the transformer of
science and technology
in fact it
is
this capacity of science and
technology that I place much of
my hope for the planet
the sustainability of our way of
life  and the possibility of achieving
good living for all humanity for a
long time,
for a long time, any
effort of the processes, the advancement of
human societies in simplistic principles and
laws, call it
dialectical materialism, a rational egoism is
destined to fail and this is a  great
well-being and to be better and promoters
of social change than any
class struggle or search for
individual wealth buy the development of
agriculture commune of humanity
transformed humanity from
urban life for the majority and much more
recently the advancement of
information technology has
transformed
industrial societies to societies  Ages of
knowledge
and I believe that in social systems or
political, economic or social systems
that are going to foresee being in the future, they will be
flashes that allow advances in
the greatest scientific and
technological advances, but also, and this is very
important, their best use for the
common good,
dear  professors colleagues wrote remains
ecuador has decided to base its
development
is the only source of wealth and well
now after exhausting more
human talent and human knowledge to
achieve development on a
sustainable basis but at the same time
on
thank you very much
president correa has  I have accepted to receive
some questions from the public that have already been given to us
in advance. I am going to
read the questions
but I am going to ask the first
question and that is how the economic engine that
has promoted the transformation that has
taken place in Ecuador is largely due to the
oil from the Amazon region, so
the challenge there is to sustain the beauty of
that biodiversity.  ity
with the extraction of the resource the detour
that is found from the work of that
biodiversity the itt process is an
effort to reconcile or reconcile
these challenges so I would like to know
your ideas and opinions about how
that project was what are the sections of the
initiative
and how to move forward  with the
sustainable extraction of oil in the region very
well thank you very much for that question
first of all I want to specify something
today lincoln sport personal income is
important but it is not the most
important source of
income in our country
oil income represents 20
percent of the total budget of
course having high prices is good
but this does not explain everything that happens in
ecuador
we have renegotiated the
oil contracts today against because the
contracts are from before they were called
paris contracts with web passions
these contracts were established in
years to come when
the cost was about 1  6
dollars and the companies gave the state to the
government at 245 dollars per barrel
then the prices skyrocketed
well they reached 60 or 70 dollars per
barrel and they continue to give us 45 dollars per
barrel
this in accordance with the
benefit contracts so giving up attention
to the situations is  Conversely, they
receive a fixed amount per barrio lingual
footballers
of 10 or 12 dollars depending on the
extraction costs and a
reasonable rent of reasonable utility for
them and the rest depending on the price
mind
and 200 whatever that is for the owner of the
oil  In other words, the people and mediums,
so what I want to say is a
visit to a hub in this situation outside,
nothing very expensive and having high prices
for oil was
useless because all the
money went to the companies
in terms of the initiative  yasuní
of what I just said is about the
yasuní initiative itt is the concept
ayto cabal of new division lewis jones
do it from the new division  initial work sion
and that was the Yasuní initiative, that
is to say, to
break this unfair division of
labor to propose to the world
why we don't all eat our
responsibility to combat etc. so
we proposed to the world to keep
the largest oil reserve
in the country on earth the partial  and not totally
but if the reserve is partially and not
totally the duty is located in a
highly biodiverse region in fact it is
a national park and we spent
those years watching to collect money
the proposal was like this we
sacrifice our income big but
but at least
contribute half of the money that
we are giving up and we spent six years
trying to convene
large countries for what rate to contribute to
the initiative and in that sense
the financial dimension was a case
the initiative was not a failure in the
sense that it increases
environmental awareness in  the country has been modified
we created the according to this concept of the
new edition  n work I'm going to you
missions the concept of
net avoided emissions and that was the concept of
requesting a contribution for the initiative
from the day you are today now if
we extract that oil wendy sol
when they are forged from 1400
more or less 400 sides of emissions  co2 and they are going to give
way to logic
almost no one
had to make a decision the
most difficult decisions but the most
difficult of my continued government
that it is today to
extract and continue exploiting diesel
in the area of ​​the drawer and now I can
guarantee you  clean's presidential
decree and we have a linda's presidential decree
that orders like this farjas morales 20 parker
has more or less 100 hectares
one million hectares the area of
one million hectares
and we are going to accept less than 500 hectares
then nothing
but we are going to get more or  minus 20
billion dollars we need for
our town for the children for
on the roads for the spies
the professor at the plant
how could this be sustained  ible,
even if you don't think so, it is the
most important problem, the wache is not
oil, but rather finding a frontier and
the expansion of the agricultural frontier, and
to stop it
we have to create jobs and income in
the sectors of the economy in general
I am pressured and poor  the settlers
poverty also affects nature
and even more so with this money
bauer with almost 20 percent of the country
is protected national parks and they are
national parks etc.
of h
and well we have the national park well
parks matter so we don't have
money the means to  take care of these
important parks so a part of these
funds to continue to increase
see it financial fourth part vehicles
and other elements to console the
forest because the main problem
is not oil expansion is the creation
of the border film
blogging and link the udinese to illegal logging
and stop training and we do not
have the capacity to control it and
with this money  or we will be able to control it,
they are people opus, some opposed the
assumption of the essentials and they have
the sun times in opposition,
formations and information is manipulated,
men in construction like today, all of
Yasuní and oil
is
and 20 billion dollars 20 thousand
Millions of dollars we need to
eliminate poverty
in our country as soon as possible, so the initiative and
the decision are fully supported.
Thank you now in a joint question
with the past 22 years the provision of
Ecuador with the founder of WikiLeaks
Julian Assange and  The American
has drawn attention to the
foreign policy of Ecuador to the extent that he is willing
to adopt positions that put him as
opposed to the global community. At the same time,
his opponents criticize him for the lack
of openness and transparency towards the
media, how to reconcile his position
apparently  liberal in the case of
wikileaks vision with the criticism that
it faces internally
well if anyone  Could you explain to me what
international activity is?
I thought that Ecuador is also
part of the international community,
so I have to reconcile with the
international community.
We are also part of the
Latin America is part of the
international community. Africa is part of the
good international community
and there is a certain hegemony that
some countries try to practice and we have to
reject in any case ecuador is
a sovereign country
we have the right to grant asylum to
any indian citizen
in accordance with the united nations charter
any citizen of the world
can  request asylum to any
sovereign country then we have exercised
our sovereignty we do not have to
explain or ask anyone for permission but
do but why
julian assange is not no den yes no julian
assange no because we agree with that we
was no because we have been  according
to what he has done but because of the
guarantor  and that it is clear that there
was no guarantee of due
process for the forista for this reason, for
example, some senators
threatened
julian assange with your prosecution that they
were going to prosecute him
under a law that contemplates the
death penalty, we do not have the
penalty  of death in our country and in
accordance with the American convention on the
death of human beings and for this
reason it was for this reason that we gave him asylum
not because we have thought in accordance with
everything he has done
but because
and we do not want him
to be investigated  in sweden etc. because there
were no guarantees of hands
and how can I reconcile that with the
situation of the media in our country
well it can be reconciled perfectly
well in that our country has a
free press and freedom of expression
turcon well it has been on our country
on the list  propaganda there is
daily propaganda on the front
pages of the newspapers attacking the
governments because normally in
latin america there are two  ctor you about our I
talked to you about power in Latin America about Latin American
problems and well, the
jelly stomach problem in which it
has historically been controlled by
some elites or these elites control the
media,
the periods and oppose the government and
every public day  but
this is the corn, it is the greatest proof
that there is a freedom of the press
that knows how it can be
read about if it is on the first page
that there is no freedom of the press then it
is propaganda but I invite
everyone to visit  fun to feel
useful when governing but also to
feel sovereignty
thank you well we have time for one
more question it is a short question
fox and it has to do with the challenge that
frankly is the great diversity that is
ecuador not only in its biodiversity but
also in its  ethnic diversity can
express their points of agreement and
disagreement with the indigenous movement
again as an indigenous movement we have
several movements  indigenous organizations it is true
the largest is called with there is a pair and a
part of the koran ex opposition had the
government has been in opposition to our
government and another part of the chain but
also this ecuadorian federation of
indians is the longest running indigenous organization
in  to do in our country this
organization supports our government it
is also so support the government it
is also
good support good if you maintain an
independent position then which
indigenous movement that is the problem
because they are choosing an
indigenous leader an indigenous movement that
opposes the government to publish  and give you
coverage in the first drop in the TC
but I can count on you well you were already
born in your country the last
presidential election we won with an
overwhelming majority in the
indigenous regions we have many eyes among the
indigenous peoples but there are also
some difficult clients  who are opposed
are our government because well in
some cases they are from  power right and
others
the extreme left according to themselves
are from the left left for example
the extreme left
but wants to assume that I do not want to
take control without winning the
elections but that is not democracy
and they are requesting impossible things
so it is not possible to reconcile with
Even more so, it
is not politically correct to say it,
but it is the truth,
in any case, many rape and King
Brawn. In any case, I can tell you that
we feel very proud to enjoy
great support among the majority of the
indigenous community present. Correale
congratulated you and  your country for the
transformation that I have seen in
recent years and thank you very much because
today to buy
thank you very much